care homes are the sanctuaries to
safeguard the most vulnerable
and when dealing with the biggest viral
threat of our time
for those inside there has always been a
choice whether to be protected
but as of october it will be illegal to
work in a care home in england
if you haven't been vaccinated against
covert 19.
each to their own but i don't want it
forced on me against my wishes it's
wrong
there's outrage from some like andy who
are faced with a 16-week
countdown knowing it could cost them
their jobs
i've been tested every week virtually
since they brought the tests out and
i've been negative every time
and i've followed the restrictions as
best i can
and i just don't want to be forced into
the position
of having a vaccine against my wishes
and
it will mean i will leave my job if they
do and try it put this through
the law won't be limited to health care
staff hairdressers and tradespeople
will also need to be vaccinated to gain
entry
those in the care sector say it's a
slippery slope
just removing a handful of people from
each employee if they refuse a
vaccination is going to give us enormous
problems
so i agree with the vaccine but forcing
people and then having to sack them
after all their hard work doesn't seem
right to me
according to nhs figures 84 of eligible
workers in care homes for older people
in england
have received their first dose of the
vaccine that means
more than 75 000 haven't
here in wandsworth just under 27 of care
home staff who work with the elderly
have not had
their covert jab vaccine hesitancy is
thought to still
be an issue but there are also
logistical problems at play with
odd shift patterns causing problems when
booking appointments
residents of grace well ascot are
neighbors to one of the biggest races in
england
but outside of their doors there's a
global race between the virus and the
vaccine
here they're relieved all staff members
are fully inoculated
by choice after all you're looking after
sick people or infirm people rather
so the more things that you help
safeguard their lives the better it is
but it wasn't without its challenges
there were difficult conversations but
it was it was about reassurance it was
never about bullying
it was about educating it was about
understanding
why there was reticence why somebody was
maybe a little scared
a consultation on the mandatory
immunising of nhs workers in hospitals
opens tomorrow for the past 18 months
they have been saving lives
now they may not get a choice on whether
to potentially save more
ash naharing sky news